The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: One more
exacting lecture on hashing.
And a couple reminders.
I don't want to start out
saying unpopular things,
but we do have a quiz coming
up next week on Tuesday.
There will not be a
lecture next Tuesday,
but there will be a quiz.
7:30 to 9:30 Tuesday evening.
I will send announcement.
There's going to
be a couple rooms.
Some of you will
be in this room.
Some of you will have to
go to a different room,
since this room
really can't hold
180 students taking a quiz.
All right?
So hashing.
I'm pretty excited
about this lecture,
because I think as I was
talking with Victor just
before this, if there's one
thing you want to remember
about hashing and you want
to go implement a hash table,
it's open addressing.
It's the simplest way
that you can possibly
implement a hash table.
You can implement a hash
table using an array.
We've obviously talked
about link lists
and chaining to implement hash
tables in previous lectures,
but we're going to actually get
rid of pointers and link lists,
and implement a hash table using
a single array data structure,
and that's the notion
of open addressing.
Now in order to get
open addressing to work,
there's no free lunch, right?
So you have a simple
implementation.
It turns out that in order to
make open addressing efficient,
you have to be a little
more careful than if you're
using the hash
tables with chaining.
And we're going to have
to make an assumption
about uniform hashing.
I'll say a little
bit more about that.
But it's a different assumption
from simple uniform hashing
that Eric talked about.
And we'll state this
uniform hashing assumption.
And we look at what the
performance is of open
addressing under
this assumption.
And this is assumption
is going to give us
a sense of what good
hash functions are
for open addressing applications
or for open addressing
hash tables.
And finally we'll talk
about cryptographic hashing.
This is not really
6006 material,
but it's kind of cool material.
It has a lot of applications
in computer security
and cryptography.
And so as we'll describe the
notion of a cryptographic hash,
and we'll talk about a couple
of real simple and pervasive
applications like
password storage
and file corruption detectors
that you can implement
using cryptographic
hash functions, which
are quite different from
the regular hash functions
that we're using in hash tables.
Be it chaining hash tables or
open addressing hash tables.
All right?
So let's get started and
talk about open addressing.
This is another approach
to dealing with collisions.
If you didn't have
collisions, obviously an array
would work, right?
If you could somehow guarantee
that there were no collisions.
When you have
collisions, you have
to worry about the
chaining and ensuring
that you can still find
the keys even though you
had two keys that collided
into the same slot.
And we don't want
to use chaining.
The simplest data structure that
we can possibly use are arrays.
Back when I was a grad student,
I went through and got a PhD
writing programs in C, never
using any other structure
than arrays, because I
didn't like pointers.
And so open addressing
is a way that you
can implement hash tables
doing exactly this.
And in particular,
what we're going to do
is assume an array
structure with items.
And we're going to assume
that this one item-- at most
one item per slot.
So m has to be greater
than or equal to n, right?
So this is important because
we don't have link lists.
We can't arbitrarily
increase the storage
of a slot using
a chain, and have
n, which is the
number of elements,
be greater than m, right?
Which you could in the link
list table with chaining.
But here you only have
these area locations,
these indices that you
can put items into.
So it's pretty much guaranteed
that if you want a working open
addressing hash table that m,
which is the number of slots
in the table, should be greater
than or equal to the number
of elements, all right?
That's important.
Now how does this work.
Well, we're going to have
this notion of probing.
And the notion of
probing is that we're
going to try to see if
we can insert something
into this hash table,
and if you fail
we're actually
going to recompute
a slightly different
hash for the key
that we're trying to
insert, the key value
pair that we're
trying to insert.
All right?
So this is an iterative
process, and we're
going to continually probe
until we find an empty slot
into which we can insert
this key value pair.
The key should index into it.
So you do have
different hashes that
are going to be computed
based on this probing
notion for a given key.
All right?
And so what we need
now is a hash function
that's different from the
standard hash functions
that we've talked about
so far, which specifies
the order of slots to
probe, which is basically
to try for a key.
And this is going to be true
for insert, search, and delete,
which are three
basic operations.
And they're a little bit
different, all right?
Just like they were different
for the chaining hash table,
they're different here, but
they're kind of more different
here.
And you'll see what I mean
when we go through this.
And this is not
just for one slot.
It's going to specify
an order of slots.
And so our hash
function h is going
to take the universe
of keys and also take
what we're going to
call the trial count.
So if you're lucky-- well, you
get lucky in your first trial.
And if you're not, you hope to
get lucky in your second trial,
and so on and so forth.
But the hash function is
going to take two arguments.
It's going to take the
key as an argument,
and it's going to take a trial,
which is an integer between 0
to n minus 1, all right?
And it's going to produce-- just
like the chaining hash function
it's going to produce a number
between 0 and m minus 1, right?
Where m is the number
of slots in the table.
All right.
So that's the story.
In order to ensure that you
are using the hash table
corresponding to open addressing
properly, what you want
is-- and this is an important
property-- that h k 1,
so that's a key
that you're given.
And this could be an
arbitrary key, mind you.
So arbitrary key k.
And what you have in
terms of the slots that
are being computed is
this, h k 1, h k 2,
and so on and so forth
to h k n minus 1.
And what you want
is for this vector
to be a permutation of 0
1 and so on to n minus 1.
And the reason for this
hopefully is clear.
It's because you want
to be able to use
the entirety of your hash table.
You don't want particular
slots to go unused.
And when you get to the point
where the number of elements n
is pretty close to m, and maybe
there's just one slot left, OK?
And you want to fill up this
last slot with this key k
that you want to put
in there, and what
you want to be able to say is
that for this arbitrary key k
that you want to put in there
that the one slot that's free--
and it could be that first slot.
It could be the 17th slot.
Whatever-- That eventually
the sequence of probes
is going to be able to allow
you to insert into that slot.
All right?
And we generalize
this notion into
the uniform hashing
assumption in a few minutes,
but hopefully this makes
sense from a standpoint
of really load
balancing the table
and ensuring that all
slots in the table
are sort of equal
opportunity slots.
That you're going to be able to
put keys in them as long as you
probe long enough that you're
going to be able to get there.
Now of course the
fact that you're
using one particular slot
for one particular key
depends on the order
of keys that you're
inserting into this table.
Again, you'll see that as we go
through an example, all right?
So that's the set up.
That's the open
addressing notion.
And that as you
can see, we're just
going to go through
a sequence of probes
and our hash function
is going to tell us
what the sequences is, and
so we don't need any pointers
or anything like that.
So let's take a look at how
this might work in practice.
So maybe the easiest thing to
do is to run through an example,
and then I'll show
you some pseudocode.
But let's say that
I have a table here,
and I'm going to concentrate
on the insert operation.
And I'm going to start inserting
things into this table.
And right here I have
seven slots up there.
So let's say that I want to
insert 586 into the table,
and I compute h of 586 comma
1, and that gives me 1.
OK?
This is the first insert.
So I'm going to go ahead and
stick 586 in here, all right?
And then I insert, for
argument's sake, 133.
I insert 204 out here.
And these are all things
because the hash table is empty.
481 out here and so on.
And because the
hash table is empty,
my very first trial is
successful, all right?
So h of 481-- I'm not going to
write this all out, but h 481 1
happens to be 6 and so on.
All right?
Now I get to the point
where I want to insert 496.
And when I try to insert
496, I have h 496 1.
It happens to be 4.
OK?
So the first thing that
happens is I go in here,
and I say oops.
This slot is occupied,
because this-- I'm
going to have a special flag
associated with an empty slot,
and we can say it's none.
And if it's not none,
then it's occupied.
And 204 is not equal to none.
So I look at this, and I say
the first probe actually failed.
OK?
And so h 496 1 equals 4 fails,
so I need to go do h 496 2.
And h 496 2 may also fail.
You might be in a situation
where h 496 2 gives you 586.
So this was h 496 1 h
496 2 might give you 586.
And finally it may be that h 496
3, which is your third attempt,
equals 3.
So you go in, and you say great.
I can insert 496.
And let me write
that in bold here.
Out there.
All right?
So pretty straightforward.
In this case, you've gone
through three trials in order
to find an empty slot.
And so the big
question really here is
other than taking care of
search and delete, how long is
this process going to take?
All right?
And I'm talking about
that in a few minutes,
but let me explain,
now that you've
seen insert, how search
would work, right?
Or maybe I get one of
you guys to explain to me
once you have insert,
how would search work?
Someone?
Someone from the back?
No one.
You guys are always
answering questions.
Yeah, all the way in the back.
AUDIENCE: Would you
just do the same kind
of probing [INAUDIBLE] where you
find it or you don't find it?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you do exactly.
It's very similar to insert.
You have a situation
where you're
going to none would
indicate an empty slot.
And you can think of
this as being a flag.
And in the case of insert,
what you did was you--
insert k v would
say keep probing.
I'm not going to write
the pseudocode for it.
Keep probing until an
empty slot is found.
And then when it's
found, insert item.
And as long as you have
the permutation property
that we have up there, and
given that m is greater than
or equal to n, you're
guaranteed that insert
is going to find a slot.
OK?
That's the good news.
Now it might take
awhile, and so we
have a talk about performance
a bit later, but it'll work.
OK?
Now search is a
little bit different.
You're searching for a
key k, and you essentially
say you're going
to keep probing.
And you say as long as
the slots encountered
are occupied by
keys not equal to k.
So every time you
probe, you go in there
and you say I got a key.
I found a hash for it.
I go to this particular slot.
I look inside of it,
and I check to see
whether the key that's
stored inside of it
is the same as the
key I'm searching for.
If not, I go to the next trial.
If it is, then I return it.
Right?
So that's pretty much it.
And we keep probing until you
either encounter k or find
an empty slot.
And this is the key.
No pun intended.
A notion which is that when
you find an empty slot,
it means that you have
failed to discover this key.
You fail to-- yeah,
question back there?
AUDIENCE: What happens if you
were to delete a key though?
PROFESSOR: I'll make you answer
that question for a cushion.
So we'll get to
delete in a minute.
But I want to make
sure you're all
on board with insert and search.
OK?
So these are actually fairly
straightforward in comparison
to delete.
It's not like delete is
much more complicated,
but there is a subtlety there.
And so that's kind
of neat, right?
I mean this actually works.
So if you had a situation where
you were just accumulating
keys, and you're looking for
the number of distinct elements
in the stream of data
that was coming in,
and that was pretty much it
with respect to your program,
you'd never have to delete
keys, and this would be all
that you'd have to implement.
Right?
But let's talk about delete.
Every once in awhile we'd
want to delete a key?
Yeah, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about search.
Why do you stop searching
once you find an empty slot?
PROFESSOR: Because
you're searching.
So what that means
is that you're
looking to see if this key
were already in the table.
And if key were
already in the table,
you want to return the value
associated with that key.
If you find an empty
slot, since you're
using the same deterministic
sequence of probes
that you would have if
you had inserted it,
then-- that make sense?
Good.
All right.
So so far so good?
That's what works for
insert and search.
Let's talk delete.
So back there.
How does delete work?
AUDIENCE: Well
[INAUDIBLE] if you
search until you find
the none and assume
that the key you're searching
for was not put in there.
But let's say you had one
that was in that slot before
and it got put back
in, but then you
delete the one that
was in the slot before.
PROFESSOR: Great, great.
You haven't told me
how to fix it yet,
but do you have
the guts for this?
No.
OK, I think this
veers to the right.
I always wanted to do this
to somebody in the back.
All right.
Whoa.
All right, good catch.
All right.
OK.
So you pointed out
the problem, and I'm
going to ask somebody
else for a solution.
All right?
But here's the problem.
Here's the problem,
and we can look
at it from a standpoint of
that example right there.
Let's say for argument's
sake that I'm searching-- now
I've done all of the inserts
that I have up there, OK?
So I've inserted 496.
All right?
Then I delete 586
from the table, OK?
I delete 586 from the table.
So let's just say
that what I end up
doing-- I have 586,
133, 496, and then
I have 204, and then a 481.
And this is 0, 1, 2, et cetera.
So I'm deleting 586, and let's
say I replace it with none.
OK?
Let's just say I
replace it with none.
Now what happens is that when
I search for 496, according
to this search algorithm
what am I going to get?
AUDIENCE: None.
PROFESSOR: Well the first slot
I'm going to look at is 1,
and according to this
search algorithm,
I find an empty slot, right?
And when I find
an empty slot, I'm
going to say I
failed in the search.
If you encounter k, you succeed
and return the key value pair,
right?
Success means you
return the value.
And if you encounter
an empty slot,
it means that you've
decided that this key is not
in the table.
And you say couldn't
find it, right?
That make sense?
So this is obviously
wrong, right?
Because I just inserted
496 into the table.
So this would fail incorrectly.
So failed to find
the key, which is OK.
I mean failure is OK
if the key isn't there.
But you don't want
to fail incorrectly.
Right?
Everyone buy that?
Good.
All right.
So how do I fix it.
Someone else?
How do I fix this?
Someone who doesn't
have a cushion.
All right, you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you can
mark that spot by a, and when
search comes across a,
you just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, great answer.
We're now going to have to do
a couple of different things
for insert and search, OK?
It's going to be
subtly different,
but the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to
have this flag,
and I'll just call
it delete me flag.
OK?
And we're going to say that
when I delete something,
replace deleted item
with not the non flag,
but a different flag that
we'll call delete me.
Is different from none.
And that's going
to be important,
because now that you
have a different flag,
and you replace
586 with delete me,
you can now do different things
in insert versus search, right?
So in particular,
what you would do
is you'd have to
modify this slightly,
because the notion
of an empty slot
means that you're
looking for none, right?
And all it means is that--
well actually in some sense,
the pseudo code
doesn't really change
because if you say
you either encounter k
or you would-- even if
you encounter a delete me,
you keep going.
All right?
That's the important thing.
So I guess it does
change, because I assume
that you have only
two cases here,
but what you really have
now are three cases.
The three cases are
when you're doing
the search is that you
encounter the key, which
is the easy case.
You return it.
You return the value.
Or you can encounter a
delete me flag, in which case
you keep going.
OK?
And if you encounter
an empty slot, which
corresponds to none,
at that point you know
you failed and the key
doesn't exist in the table.
All right?
So let me just write that out.
Insert treats delete
me the same as none.
But search keeps going
and treats it differently.
And that's pretty much it.
So what would happen
in our example?
Well, going through
exactly the same example,
we started from here, and
then we decided to delete 586.
And so if we replaced 586 not
with none, but with delete me,
and the next time around
when you search for 496,
you're searching for 496.
And what would
happen is that you
would go look at 586-- the
slot that contained 586,
and you see that there's
a delete me flag in there.
And so you go to the next trial.
And then in the next trial, you
discover that, in this case,
you have-- I'm sorry.
I had 204 first as
the first trial,
and then in the second
trial I had 586.
And I would continue
beyond the second trial
and get to third trial, and in
fact return 496 in this case.
I would get to returning
496 in my third trial, which
is exactly what I want.
The interesting thing here is
that you can reuse storage.
I mean the whole
point of deleting
is that you can take the storage
and insert other keys in there.
Once you've freed
up the storage.
And you can do that by
making insert treat delete me
the same as the none.
So the next time you
want to insert you
could-- if you happen to index
into the index corresponding
to 586, you can override that.
The delete me flag goes
away, and some other key--
call it 999 or something--
would get in there.
And you're all set with that.
OK?
Any questions?
This all makes sense?
So you could imagine coding
this up with an array structure
is fairly straightforward.
What remains here
to be discussed
is how well does
this work, right?
You have this extra requirement
on the hash function
corresponding to creating
an extra argument
as an input to it, which
is this trial count.
And you'd like to have this
nice property of corresponding
to a permutation.
Can we actually design
hash functions like this?
And we'll take a look
at a bad hash function,
and then at a better one.
So let's talk about
probing strategies, which
is essentially the same
as taking a hash function
and changing it
so it is actually
applicable to open addressing.
So the notion of
linear probing is
that you do h k i
equals h prime k, which
is some hash function
that you've chosen,
plus i mod m, where this is
an ordinary hash function.
OK?
So that looks pretty
straightforward.
What happens here?
Does this satisfy the
permutation argument?
Before I forget.
Does it satisfy the
permutation property
that I want h k 1, h k 2, h k
m minus 1 to be a permutation?
That make sense?
Yep, yep.
Because I then I start adding.
The mod is precisely kind
of this round robin cycle,
so it's going to
satisfy the permutation.
That's good.
What's wrong with this?
Someone?
AUDIENCE: The fact that
[INAUDIBLE] keys, which they're
all filled, then if you hit
anywhere in here [INAUDIBLE]
list of consecutive keys.
AUDIENCE: Right.
That's excellent.
Excellent, excellent answer.
So this notion of
clustering is basically
what's wrong with
this probing strategy.
And in fact, I'm not going to
do this particular analysis,
but I'll give you a sense of why
the statement I'm going to make
is true.
But the notion of
clustering is that you
start getting consecutive
groups of occupied slots, OK?
Which keep growing.
And so these clusters
get longer and longer.
And if you have a
big cluster, it's
more likely to
grow bigger, right?
Which is bad.
This is exactly the wrong thing
for load balancing, right?
And clustering is the reverse
of load balancing, right?
If you have a bunch
of clumps and you
have a bunch of empty space
in your table, that's bad.
Right?
The problem with
linear probing is
that once you start getting a
cluster, given the, let's say,
the randomness in the hash
function, and h prime k
is a pretty good hash function
and can randomly go anywhere.
Well, if you have 100 slots and
you have a cluster of size 4,
well there's a for 4/100
chance, which is obviously
four times greater than
1/100, even I can do that,
to go into those four slots.
And if you going
into those four slots
you're going to keep
going down to the bottom,
and you're going to make that
a cluster of size five, right?
So that's the problem
the linear probing,
and you can essentially
argue through making
some probabilistic assumptions
that if, in fact, you
use linear probing that you
lose your average constant time
look up in your hash table
for most load factors.
So what's happening out
here pictorially really
is that you have a table and
let's say you have a cluster.
And this is your cluster.
So if your h k 1--
it doesn't really
matter what it is-- but h
k i maps to this cluster,
then you're going
to-- linear probing
says that the next thing
you're going to try
is if you map to
42 in the cluster,
the next thing
you're going to try
is 43, 44, until you get maybe
to this slot here, which is 57,
for argument's sake.
Right?
So you're going to
keep going, and you're
going to try 15 times in
this relatively dumb fashion
to go down to get to the
open slot, which is 57.
And oh, by the way,
at the end of this you
just increased your
cluster length by one.
All right?
So it doesn't really work.
And in fact, under reasonable
probabilistic assumptions
in terms of what your
hash functions are,
you can say that when you have
alpha, which is essentially
your load factor, which is
n over m less than 0.99,
you see clusters
of size log n, OK?
Right.
So this is a
probabilistic argument,
and you're assuming that you
have a hash function that's
a pretty good hash function.
So h prime k can be this perfect
hash function, all right?
So there's a problem here
beyond the choice of h
prime k, which is this hash
function that worked really
well for chaining.
All right?
And the problem here is the
linear probing aspect of it.
So what does that mean?
If you have clusters
of theta log n,
then your search and
your insert are not
going to be constant
time anymore.
Right?
Which is bad in a
probabilistic sense.
OK?
So how do we fix that?
Well, one strategy that
works reasonably well
is called double hashing.
And it literally
means what it says.
You have to run a
couple of hashes.
And so the notion of double
hashing is that you have h k i
equals h1 k plus i h2 k mod m.
And h1 and h2 are just
ordinary hash functions.
OK?
Now the first thing
that we need to do
is figure out how we can
guarantee a permutation, right?
Because we still have
that requirement,
and it was OK for the
linear probing part,
but you still have
this requirement
that you need a permutation.
And so those of you who
are into number theory,
can you tell me what property,
what neat property of h2 and m
can we ask for to
guarantee a permutation?
Do you have a question?
You already do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
relatively prime.
OK, good.
So I figured some of
you knew the answer,
but I've seen you before.
Right.
Exactly right.
Relatively prime.
Just hand it to Victor.
So h2 k and m being
relatively prime,
if that implies a permutation.
It's similar to
what we had before.
You're multiplying this
by i. i keeps increasing,
and you're going to roll around.
All right?
I mean you could
do a proof of it,
but I'm not going to bother.
The important thing
here is that you can now
do something as simple as
m equals 2 raised to r,
and h2 k for all k is odd,
and now you're in great shape.
You can have your
array to be 2 raised
to something, which is
what you really want.
And you just use h2 k.
You could even take a
regular hash function
and truncate it to
make sure it's odd.
You can do a bunch of things.
There's hash functions
that produce odd values,
and you can use that.
All right?
And so double hashing works
fairly well in practice.
It's a good way of getting
open addressing to work.
And in order to prove that
open addressing actually
works to the level at
which chaining works,
we have to make an
assumption corresponding
to uniform hashing.
And I'm not going to
actually do a proof,
but it'll be in the notes.
But I do want to talk about
the theorem and the result
that the theorem
implies, assuming
you have the uniform
hashing assumption.
And let me first
say that this is not
the same as simple
uniform happening, which
talks about the independence of
keys in terms of their mapping
to slots.
The uniform hashing
assumption says
that each key is
equally likely to have
any one of the m
factorial permutations--
so we're talking about
random permutations
here-- as its probe sequence.
All right?
This is very hard
to get in practice.
You can get pretty close
using double hashing.
But nobody's discovered
a perfect hash function,
deterministic hash function
that satisfies this property.
At least not that I know off.
So what does this imply?
Assuming that you have
this and double hatching
gives you this property, to a
large extent what this means is
that if alpha is
n over m, you can
show that the cost of operations
such as search, insert, delete,
et cetera.
And in particular
we talk about insert
is less than or equal to 1
divided by 1 minus alpha.
OK?
So obviously this goes
as alpha tends to 1.
As alpha tends to 1, the load
factor in the table gets large,
and the number of
expected probes
that you need to do when
you get an insert grows.
And if alpha is 0.99,
you're going, on average,
require 100 probes.
It's a constant number, but
it's a pretty bad constant.
Right?
So you really want alpha
to be fairly small.
And in practice it
turns out that you
have to re-size you're
open addressing table
when alpha gets beyond
about 0.5, 0.6 or so,
because by then you're
really in trouble.
Remember this is an average
case we're talking about.
All of this is using a
probabilistic assumption.
But as you get to
high alphas, suddenly
by the time you get to
0.7, open addressing
doesn't work well in relation
to an equivalent table
with the overall
number of slots that
correspond to a
changing table, OK?
So open addressing
is easy to implement.
It uses less memory because
you don't need pointers.
But you better be careful that
your alpha stays around 0.5
and no more.
So all that means is
you can still use it.
You just have to
re-size your table.
You have slightly
different strategies
for resizing your
table when you use open
addressing as opposed
to chaining hash tables.
All right?
So that's a summary
of open addressing.
I want to spend some time
on cryptographic hashes
in the time that I have left.
I guess I have a
few minutes left.
But any questions
about open addressing?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: On this
delete part, what's
going to happen if, say, you
fill the table up and then
delete everything, and
then you start searching.
Isn't that going to
be bad because it's
going to search
through everything?
PROFESSOR: So that's right.
The bad thing about
open addressing
is that delete isn't
instantaneous, right?
In the sense that if you deleted
something from the link list
in your chaining
table, then even
if you went to that same
thing, the chain got smaller,
and that helps you, because
your table now has lower load.
But there's a delay
associated with load
when you have the
delete me flag.
OK?
So in some sense the alpha
that you want to think about,
you should be careful as
to how you define alpha.
And that's one of
the reasons why
when you get alpha
being 0.5, 0.6
you get into trouble, because
if you have all these delete
me flags, they're
still hurting you.
AUDIENCE: And when
you resize do those
delete me flags get deleted?
PROFESSOR: When you
completely resize
and you redo the
whole thing, then you
can clean up the delete me's
and turn them into nones
because you're rehashing it.
All right.
So yeah, back there.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, can you explain
how you got the equation
that the cost of operation
insert is less than
or equal to 1 over [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
a longish proof,
but let me explain to
you how that comes out.
Basically the intuition
behind the proof
is that we're going to
assume some probability p.
And initially you're
going to say something
like if the table, your p--
I'll just write this out here--
is m minus n divided by m.
So what is that?
Right now I have n
elements in the table,
and I have m slots, OK?
So the probability that my very
first trial is going to succeed
is going to be m minus n
divided by m, because these
are the number of empty slots.
And assuming my
permutation argument,
I could go into one of them.
And so that's what I have here.
And if you look at what this
is, this is 1 minus alpha, OK?
And so then you run
off and you remember
6041 or the high school
probability course
that you take, and you
say generally speaking,
you're going to be no worse
than p for every trial.
And so if you assume
the worst and say
every trial has a
probability of success of p,
the expected number
of trials is 1/p, OK?
And that's how you got
the 1 over 1 minus alpha.
So you'll see that written
in gory detail in the notes.
All right?
OK.
Expected to have
a little more time
in terms of talking about
cryptographic hashes,
but cryptographic hashes are
not going to be on the quiz.
This is purely material FYI.
For your interest only.
And again I have
some notes on it,
but I want to give you a sense
of the other kinds of hashes
that exist in the
world, I guess.
And hashes that are used for
many different applications.
So maybe the best way
of motivating this
is through an example.
So let's talk about
an example that
is near and dear to every
security person's heart
and probably to people who
aren't interested in security
as well, which is
password storage.
So think about how,
let's say, Unix systems
work when you type
in your password.
You're typing in your
password [INAUDIBLE],
and this is true for
other systems as well,
but you have a password.
And my password is a permutation
of my first daughters
first name.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, but haven't
given it away, right?
Haven't given it away.
And so this password
is something
that I'm typing in
every day, right?
Now the sum check
that needs to happen
to ensure that I'm typing
in the right password.
So what is a dumb
way of doing things.
What's a dumb way
of building systems?
AUDIENCE: Storing [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is
kind of a freebie.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In situ hashing.
That's better.
So you'd store it.
I offered the dumb way.
So there's a perfectly
valid answer.
So you could clearly store
this in plain text in some file
and you could call it
slash etc slaw password.
And you could make it
read for the work, right?
And that'd be great, and
people do that, right?
But what you would
rather do is you
want to make sure that even
the sysadmin doesn't know
my password or your
password, right?
So how do you do that?
Well you do that using a
cryptographic hash that
has this interesting
property that is one way, OK?
And what that means is
that given h of x-- OK,
this is the value
of the hash-- it
is very hard to find the
x such that x basically
hashes to this value.
So if h of x equals
let's call it q,
then you're only given h of x.
And so what do you do now?
Well, it's beautiful.
Assuming you have this one way
hash, this cryptographic hash,
in your etc slash
password file, you
have something like
login name, [INAUDIBLE],
which happens to be the hash
of my daughter's first name,
or something.
But this is what's stored
in there and the same thing
for a bunch of
different users, right?
So when I log in and I type
in the actual password,
what does the system do?
What does the system do?
It hashes it.
It takes x prime, which is
the typed in password, which
may or may not be
equal to my password,
because somebody else might
be trying to break in,
or I just mistyped, or forgot
my daughter's first name,
which would be bad.
And it will just check to see--
it doesn't need x, because it's
stored h of x in the system,
so it doesn't need x.
So if we just compare
against what I typed in,
it would compute the hash again.
And then would let me in
assuming that these things
matched and would not
let me in if it didn't.
So now we can talk about-- and
I don't have time for this,
but you can certainly
read up on it on Wikipedia
and a bunch in the notes.
You can talk about
what properties
should this hash function
have, namely one way collision
resistance, in order
to solve these problems
and other problems.
I'm happy to stick around
and answer questions.